introducing Zink on Google cloud  platform the tool for rendering your  imagination  now you can spin up processors as needed  to bring your ideas to life simply  choose your processor then render away  until your shot is complete speed is key  when rendering high resolution animation  especially for 4k and VR renders and  remember per minute billing equals major  savings get billed only for what you use  never for what you don't our plug and  play software makes cloud rendering as  easy as two steps with zinc on Google  cloud platform this cute little creature  has the power to do just about anything  redeem up to $800 in credit to tap the  rendering power of zinc on Google cloud  platform